good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is SCP 3063 object
class Keter special containment
procedures newly discovered SCP 3063
manifestations are to be reported
immediately and destroyed as soon as
possible by whatever means are
appropriate all foundation buildings and
the residences of all foundation
personnel are to be equipped with the
most effective insect control measures
available and no point should personnel
ever interact with or acknowledge SCP
3063 manifestations outside of
immediately destroying said
manifestation any foundation personnel
or civilian individuals known or
suspected to have made an agreement with
SCP 3063
are to be immediately contained in the
nearest foundation facility equipped
with appropriate containment facilities
until the event of said individuals
death once the affected individual has
died their remains are to be incinerated
along with any organisms that may have
emerged from them during their
containment individuals affected by SCP
3063 do not require food or other
external attention and under no
circumstances are they to be removed
from containment while alive
[Music]
if affected individuals are unable to be
contained for any reason every effort
should be made by foundation operatives
to kill set individuals before the event
of their natural death if this is
possible or if affected individuals are
not discovered until their deaths mobile
task force beta 5 is to enact procedure
18 is lip description SCP 30 63 is a
telepathic class 5 reality bending
entity as CP 30 63 invariably manifests
as a physiologically non-anomalous adult
male housefly Muzyka doméstica it is
currently believed that only one
manifestation of SCP 30 63 exists at any
given time but this has yet to be
confirmed manifestations are to be
considered destroyed and they have
sustained damage that would be
sufficient to kill a non-anomalous
housefly
after which SCP 30 63 will manifest
elsewhere on earth no manifestation
event has been observed as of yet and
that is not currently known whether SCP
30 63 manifests as an entirely new
individual housefly or simply inhabits
the body of an existing housefly
SCP 30 63 manifestations operate with a
single goal namely making an agreement
with an individual the terms of such
agreement vary greatly but almost always
involve SCP 30 63 promising an
individual any single thing they greatly
desire in exchange for an unspecified
price such offers have included large
sums of money the love of other
individuals political power and reality
bending ability it is hypothesized that
SCP 30 63 reads the thoughts of its
target to tailor an offer
specific to them as CP 30 63 refuses to
discuss anything other than the terms of
its agreement
if an individual accepts the terms of
agreement the SCP 3063 manifestation
will immediately combust and die at
which point the individual will receive
what they were promised if an individual
does not accept SCP 3063 will continue
to attempt to tempt them with larger and
larger offers until either the
individual accepts or the manifestation
is destroyed if the SCP 3063
manifestation is destroyed successive
manifestations will continue to contact
the individual until they consent to
this agreement after a period of 2376
days from the moment that agreement with
SCP 3063 is made affected individuals
will undergo a process as detailed
fertilized eggs representing virtually
all known species of the order diptera
will spontaneously appear within the
lungs throat stomach intestines sinuses
ear canals rectum urethra and muscle
tissues of an affected individual the
number of such eggs typically ranges
from 5,000 to 20,000 the eggs will hatch
naturally and the resulting maggots will
begin consuming tissues of the affected
individuals for between 3 and 14 days in
order to escape the body when this
period has elapsed the maggots will
pupate and lie dormant within 2 to 6
days pupae will emerge as adult Mao
flies newly emerged flies will continue
consuming their hosts and breeding with
each other until the host has sustained
sufficient damage and dies this
typically takes between 1 and 5 weeks
and has been known to produce upwards of
50 million individual flies when the
affected individual has died the
remaining flies will cease reproducing
and enter a stage of dormancy during
which they will eventually starve and
die
a new manifestation of SCP 3063 will
appear shortly after the death of the
affected individual affected individuals
will remain conscious for almost the
entirety of this process resulting in
great distress roughly 70% of affected
individuals will attempt suicide during
this process files generated during this
process have been determined to be
entirely non-anomalous if the affected
individual dies during any point in this
process or during the preceding 2376
days the process will stop and the Flies
will die own own method of averting this
process other than the death of the
individual has been discovered to date 6
foundation personnel have been contacted
by a CP 3063 and attempts have been made
to alter the terms of agreement to
entrap SCP 3063 into neutralizing itself
though none have met with success the
following is a partial test log of such
attempts deaths log SCP 30 63 test 30 60
3-1 tester senior researcher elizabeth
GAO parameters the death of SCP 30 63
result SCP 30 63 manifestation combusts
legs manifest within dr. gal 2376 days
after testing interpretation SCP 30 63
apparently interprets its death as the
death of a manifestation
test 3063 - - tester senior researcher
david roberts parameters the permanent
containment of SCP 3063 result SCP 3063
manifestations ceases moving and is
determined to have died the dead
instances contained within a secure
containment unit below site 63 after
2376 days Diptera eggs manifest inside
senior researcher Roberts body three
months after his death another SCP 3063
instance is confirmed interpretation
again such terms of agreements seem to
extend only to SCP 3060 three's current
manifestation just 30 63 - 3 tester dr.
Caroline Fairweather parameters a
permanent cessation of all activities of
SCP 3063 results results identical to
those of test 30 63 - 1 interpretation
it is becoming clear that permanent in
the context of SCP 3063 only extends for
the 2376 days prior to the death of the
individual test number 30 63 - for
tester senior researcher William Marlow
parameters knowledge of the true nature
of SCP 30 63
result ASEP 3063 combusts a printed copy
of this document without test log
appears before senior researcher Marlowe
process proceeds as normal
interpretation assuming SCP 3063 does
not cheat those it makes an agreement
with this document is considered to be
accurate and true test number 3060 3-5
tester dr. Patrick McGann parameters
clear understandable knowledge of SCP
3063
other than knowledge currently possessed
by the SCP foundation result SCP 3063
combusts results of this test and the
following tests appear printed before
dr. McGann who proceeds to kill himself
by puncturing his carotid artery with a
pen interpretation SCP 3063 either
possesses pre cognizant abilities or is
able to directly affect future events
test number 30 63 - 6 tester dr.
Jonathan Mabry parameters is there even
a choice result dr. Mabry experiences a
severe pulmonary embolism and later dies
on route to the Medical Centre SCP 3063
combusts interpretation see test number
30 63 - 5
any personnel contacted by a CP 3063 are
expected to report the event and then
use the opportunity to continue
neutralization efforts SCP 3063 is
believed to have been in operation for
at least 4000 years as the earliest
known records of entities and events
matching SCP 3063 s description have
been discovered in early Canaanites
settlements assuming an approximately
constant rate of activity this equates
to approximately 615 agreements made it
is entirely possible than SCP 30 63 has
been in operation for considerably
longer and foundation archaeological
teams are currently searching for
earlier recordings of events that would
indicate as such procedure is lip - 18
in the event of the death of uncontained
individuals due to SCP 3063 s effects
mole task force beta 5 is to mobilize
and administer said individual with 90
grams of cypermethrin additional
cypermethrin is to be sprayed within a
10 meter radius of the affected
individual after the individual and any
regenerated flies have died remains are
to be incinerated any civilian witnesses
are to be given a regimen of class-a
amnestics and the area is to be closed
to civilians for no less than 30 days
under the pretense of a nonspecific
toxic spill
[Music]
okay that about does it today thank you
very much for listening
you were all dismissed goodbye I would
like to give a special thank you to
Andre best [ __ ]
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]